un groupe de 15 leaders économiques
syndicaux sociaux environnementaux
propose des mesures pour relancer
l'économie du québec avec nous deux des
signataires a ni celle où qui est
professeur à l'école de politique
appliquée de l'université de sherbrooke
et yves thomas dorval pdg du conseil du
patronat du québec bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir lens a expliqué nous d'abord un
est celle où cette initiative
cette idée en fait est venue de pouvoir
assembler ensemble des acteurs du monde
syndical sociaux des milieux économiques
pour qu'on puisse réfléchir ensemble à
qu'elles sont d'abord les grands
consensus que l'on a dans la société
québécoise pour réfléchir à la crise
mais réfléchir aussi aux différents de
possibilités aux différentes mesures de
relance que le gouvernement du québec
pourrait entreprendre afin de faire en
sorte qu'elle québec se trouve dans une
situation de leader est dans une
situation où ils seront plus résilients
dans l'économie de demain
lorsqu'on sortira de la crise et quand
je regarde le document yves thomas
dorval
un document quand même de 11 pages que
cette lettre qui a été envoyée avec
toutes sortes de propositions touffu est
ce qu'on comprend que dans le plan
national de relance c'est
l'environnement qu'il faut mettre à
l'avant plan
entre autres parce que les questions de
développement durable vont permettre
d'avoir des retombées d'investissements
gouvernementaux pour un plus large
éventail de bénéficiaires si on peut
dire c'est à dire la population de façon
plus générale et surtout si on est les
six dans des projets structurants qui
ont trait au développement durable
savons également à mener pour les
générations futures un retour sur cet
investissement
donc ce sera pas seulement un
investissement à court terme mais qui
aura des retombées justement intéressant
pour les générations futures
je comprends mais le premier ni c'est
quand même sur le court terme en ce
moment ils parlent de rouvrir les petits
commerces
on entendait la banque du canada qui dit
j'ai fait mes débuts
je hais ce que est ce que
prioritairement que j'entends pas le
premier ministre parlait beaucoup
d'environnements présentement dans son
discours c'est pas ça c'est de rouvrir
relancer l'économie présentement on est
chez nous on comprend que le message
d'avoir un message d'urgence on est dans
une situation crée une situation de très
grande vulnérabilité
ceci étant dit déjà plusieurs mesures
ont été mis en place par le gouvernement
qui peuvent à terme si on les déploie
bien dans les changements de
comportement d'habitude d'aider des
citoyens on en arrive à lutter plus
efficacement contre les changements
climatiques et améliorer des conditions
environnementales
on a entendu le gouvernement parlait
d'autonomie alimentaire de fabriquer au
québec puisque le groupe propose c'est
justement de trouver des avenues pour
permettre une économie du québec soit
plus résiliente une économie québécoise
aussi qui nous permet de diminuer si on
veut la laddh notre dépendance qu'on a
face au commerce international et de
déployer notre expertise qu elles on
note chez nous le front des nouvelles
avenues
alors on va y arriver l'achat local mais
je veux rester sur la sobriété en
carbone c'est écrit dans votre document
et je cite consensus existe au québec à
l'effet que la priorité des nouveaux
investissements dans le réseau routier
doit être le maintien des actifs plutôt
que le développement de la capacité
routière
c'est l'avis du conseil du patronat oui
dans le fait partie d'un groupe quand
même sur la mobilité durable
vous savez on a un déficit
d'investissement au niveau des
infrastructures de transport collectif
alors qu'on a quand même un
investissement assez important au niveau
du transport en général de la spa
routier cependant ont-ils bien dans le
document qu'il faut moderniser
il faut juste y réparer entretenir
maintenir rendent notre infrastructure
routière actuelle beaucoup plus adapté
aux besoins d'aujourd'hui mais nos
prévisions mais il a développé davantage
si ça vous dit
en fait c'est surtout de verser
davantage d'investissements du côté de
des domaines où on a une sous
investissement c'est à dire du côté du
transport collectif mais vous avez posé
une question tout à l'air extrêmement
important il ya trois phases de départ
du gouvernement il ya celle pour aider
les entreprises et les citoyens
actuellement il ya aussi le financement
dur de la relance au niveau des
entreprises qui auront besoin die
mais ici on parle que le gouvernement
déjà mentionné qu'il va être obligé de
prendre le relais des investissements
structurants qui vont avoir un effet
plus long terme et c'est là où on dit
ben dans certains domaines
d'investissement pour l'après crise pour
faire en sorte que non seulement on va
voir aider les entreprises à passer au
travers ou mois à faire face à la
violence mais également falloir que le
gouvernement investisse davantage dans
les projets structurants pour prendre le
relais et le relais des investissements
pendant ont probablement réduite et
utiliser le fonds des générations un
échelon réorienter un peu la mission du
fonds des générations
mais c'est que l'idée d'y fonder
génération assez d'amoindrir la pression
sur les générations futures concernant
la dette
on a beaucoup parlé donc de la dette
économique et le québec avec s'est
beaucoup améliorée dans les dernières
années mais reste qu une dette
importante qu'on peut parler d'une dette
écologique et plus on utilise ces fonds
là maintenant pour transformer
l'économie québécoise et pour les
générations futures mais plus dans le
fond le fonds des générations répond à
cet objectif là donc si on est capable
de prendre ces nouvelles sommes là à
investir et l'investir dans des projets
d'infrastructure verte plus solidaire en
favorisant l'agriculture
mais ce sont les générations futures qui
font aussi en bénéficier
donc c'est vraiment dans cet esprit là
quel est le projet a été lancé sur le
chat local bon on parle de fabriquer au
québec notamment une certification et
monsieur dorval qu'on parle d'augmenter
fortement nos achats de firmes locales
est-ce qu'il faut plus d'achat local et
moins de mondialisation on est libre
échangiste en quoi l'importance puis
l'interrelation internationale d'une
chaîne d'approvisionnement et on a
besoin d'eux sort mais on regarde la
situation spécifique du québec durant
cette crise
actuellement et on parle de résilience
c'est à dire on va avoir besoin non
seulement de passer au travers mais il y
aura probablement d'autres crises
futures
à ce qu'on dit c'est pas de dire que
tout redevient protectionnistes ce qu'on
dit c'est d'abord on voit c'est
d'arrêter de jouer
la courte avec les autres parce que les
autres sont protectionnistes mais
surtout on va essayer de s'assurer que
pour à tout le moins des biens
essentiels et services essentiels pour
passer à travers les crises qu'on
connaît actuellement mais qu'on
connaîtra peut-être dans le futur mais
il faut avoir cultivé davantage notre
capacité interne un domestique de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins en
commençant par les besoins alimentaires
qui sont des besoins de base
mais c'est vrai aussi pour les soins de
santé pour les équipements protection
est instituée on le voit puis on le vit
actuellement durant la crise il ya de
télétravail en quelques secondes madame
chalus oui mais ça fait partie aussi
d'une belle orientation parce que le
secteur des transports occupe 43% après
des 500 gaz à effet de serre et à partir
du moment qu'on rend accessible une
mesure comme celle là mais ça permet aux
gens de moins voyagé de pouvoir se ce
travail et à la maison donc recréé sur
le plan familial aussi de générer des
bénéfices sur le plan de la communauté
et ça peut peut-être permettre aux
entreprises de réduire leurs grandes
infrastructures permettant d'employer
travail à la maison il ya plein de
bonnes choses dans votre lettre très
intéressante qu'on va mettre sur nos
médias sociaux merci annie chalouhi
thomas dorval
bonsoir merci à vous et à